today a bipartisan group of
congressional leaders will go to the
White House to discuss the crisis in
Syria caused by turkeys invasion new
video shows Turkish artillery firing on
Kurds in Syria vice president Mike Pence
is heading to the region to press for a
ceasefire as Turkey's president gave
Kurdish fighters a deadline of tonight
to leave a designated area along the
border Charlie d'Agata who's near the
conflict zone in neighboring Iraq shows
us Russia's growing role while the Vice
President may be headed to Turkey but
president air Dewan has already said we
will never declare a ceasefire one
person he is speaking to Russian
President Vladimir Putin another
indication of Russia's lead role on and
off the battlefield it's not just Syrian
regime forces carving up Kurdish
territory the flags on those military
vehicles are Russian and it's President
Putin he now ultimately controls the
flashpoint city of manbij an area once
dominated by US forces and their Kurdish
allies the local reporters from Russian
TV channels were seeing mocking America
in a show-and-tell of the abandoned US
military base their mess halls with food
trays stocked refrigerators coca-cola
footballs doughnuts suggesting the
troops left in a hurry
CBS News has learned that US forces
across Northeast Syria have retreated to
larger bases like kobani to begin air
lifting heavy equipment but it's a risky
operation when Turkish back militias
extremists made up of former al Qaeda
and Isis fighters came too close to an
American unit the u.s. responded with a
show of force
Apache helicopters like this buzzing in
low to deter the fighters from advancing
any further
as the war zone widens civilians
escaping the violence are running out of
places to hide with many now passing
into neighboring Iraq Russian TV is
reporting today that Syrian forces have
taken control of bases left behind by US
troops now we've seen our share of bases
like ma'am [ __ ] usually almost
everything is packed away but that look
like a place frozen in time Thank You
charlie